well what do you think about Elon just
opening the door to a journalist to see
all the emails that were sent the the
quote-unquote Twitter files
yeah that's really interesting I mean I
saw a lot of
I'm like in this weird thing where I see
I'm so I follow a lot of independent
people and I follow a lot of mainstream
journalists and that that they're very
polar opposite takes on that uh people
really quickly politicize it but to me
this thing that was fascinating is just
the transparency that I've never
received from one of the really
frustrating things to me because a lot
of this podcast has been about
interviewing tech people CEOs and so on
and they're just so guarded with
everything it's hard to get to and so
it's nice to get
um hopefully this is a signal look you
can be transparent like this is a signal
to increase transparency
hopefully so I don't yeah it's been
tribalized so quickly it's like I've
lost a lot of faith in that and
unfortunately it's been this like
bludgeon match of like
you know
if you're on the right you think it's
uncovering the greatest story ever about
Hunter Biden if you're on the left you
think they were just sharing they were
just silencing revenge porn pics of
Hunter Biden so therefore it was
justified and by the way Trump also sent
messages to Twitter so doesn't that mean
that like we should be criticized it
just like this is goes back to why I
don't touch politics is because I think
as many problems as I have I think when
you become a polit like a journalist
that not even a political journalist
when you become a journalist in politics
you have like twice the problem so I'm
like I'm happy to be well outside of
that um kind of sphere but it's an
interesting
um it is interesting it twit you know
forget Twitter files but Twitter itself
is really really interesting from uh the
virality of information transfer yeah
and from a journalistic perspective it's
like how information travels how it
becomes distributed
that's interesting what do you think
about Twitter I'm always conflicted on
Twitter because I almost hate how much I
enjoy using it because I'm like this is
like this mindless Bird app is consuming
my time
um it's this incredible networking tool
but what's weird is when I think about
my own presence on Twitter they've
almost made it too easy to like say
something that you've half thought like
the friction to send a tweet is so much
less than like if I'm gonna make a
YouTube video there's several points at
which I'm like well what's the other
side what's this what's that there's no
friction there and so one thing I've
noticed is everyone I follow on Twitter
a lot of them after reading all their
tweets I think nothing more of them
nothing less of them but there's a lot
of them that I think less of and I don't
think I've ever had an experience where
I've read read someone tweets and I
think more of them in a way and I'm like
what does that say that
yeah what is that like there's so many
people I
I admire
that the worst of them is represented in
Twitter like uh there's a there's a lot
of people there's a million examples
they become like snarky and uh sometimes
mocking and derisive and negative and
like emotional messes uh
I don't know yeah what is that
um maybe maybe we shouldn't criticize it
and accept that as like a beautiful raw
aspect of that human being but not
encompassing not representing the full
interview it does reflect like it's
impossible to not reflect it to some
extent or you'd have to counter that
bias really carefully because that is
them it is a thought they had it's just
probably something that should have been
an unexpressed thought perhaps
um so yeah I I kind of Wonder like my
I'm like should I be on Twitter but the
problem is is it's such a great place
where so many
like so much of the news happens on
Twitter so much of
the journalism breaks on Twitter even
people in the New York Times they'll
tweet their scoop you know like they'll
put that out on Twitter first so it's
this really weird thing where I'd love
to be off it and it's like too useful
for my job but I kind of I kind of hate
it no no you need to well it depends but
from my perspective you should be on it
oh wow certainly definitely am yeah so
like a coffee Zilla should definitely be
on Twitter but
have uh developed the calluses and the
uh the strength to um not give in to the
sort of the Lesser aspects like that
because you're like us you're you're
silly you're funny you could be you
could be cutting with your humor I
wouldn't give in to the um
like the darker aspects of that like low
effort negativity if you're the way you
are in your videos I would say if you're
ever negative or making fun of stuff I
think that's high effort so I would
still put a lot of effort into it like
calmly thinking through that because and
also not giving into the dopamine desire
to do to say something that's going to
get a lot of likes uh you know I have
that all the time you you use Twitter
enough you realize certain messages that
are going to get more likes than others
and uh and are usually the ones that are
Extreme More extreme yeah and like
emotional like
Lex is an idiot or like lexism the
greatest human being ever yeah it's much
better than oh wow what a polite nuanced
conversation I can tell you right now
which of those three tweets isn't going
to perform well
yeah yeah so I I think the Extreme's
okay if you believe it okay I will
sometimes say
um positive things I said that the the
the the Twitter files release was
historic of course this before I
realized I mean I I the reason I said it
is not is because the transparency it's
so refreshing to see some any love of
transparency
and then of course those kinds of
comments the way Twitter does is every
side will interpret it in the worst
possible way for them and they uh will
run with it or some side when it's
political yeah one side will interpret
yes
uh I agree with that historic they might
not have even read the article they just
like they literally or the Tweet thread
and they're just like it is historic uh
historically because Hunter Biden was
finally the the collusion or whatever it
is and then the other side is like no
it's it's a nothing Burger
um but yeah that that aspect of nuance
and then it's frozen in time even with
editing there's a so tough it's It's
Tricky but if you maintain a cool head
through all of that and
um hold to your ethics and your ideas
and use it to to spread the ideas which
you do extremely well on YouTube I think
I think it could be a really powerful
platform there's no other platform that
allows for the viral spread of ideas
good ideas then
um than this and this is where like
especially with Twitter spaces
I mean where else would I see I think
twice impromptu conversations with
coffee Zilla and SPF like never yeah
nowhere else because he wasn't going to
come on my show he wasn't going to come
on some big prepared thing it's like hey
YOLO let's go into Twitter space and I
like pop up and you know what's funny
and this I hope this release is late
enough or well SPF probably won't see
this yeah
um although I'm sure he's and
unfortunately unfortunately he will oh
okay yes well
hopefully I'll have time to enact my
little plan but
um I'm hoping if he goes on any future
spaces I can like haunt him from
interview to interview which is like I
keep showing up and he's like oh I hate
this guy but I think he's he's already
kind of probably
um
has like PTSD of like in the shadows
lurks of coffee Zilla that just would
that would just it's just like uh that
really amuses me I mean there's a
I think he honestly would enjoy talking
to you there's a aspect of Twitter
spaces that's a little uncertain of like
what are we doing here because there's
there's an urgency because other voices
might want to butt in exactly exactly if
it's an intimate one-on-one where you
can like breathe like hold on a second
yeah I think it's much easier so that
sense of course space is a little bit
negative
um that there there's too many voices if
if especially if it's a very
controversial kind of thing so yeah it's
tricky but at the same time the friction
it's so easy to just jump in yeah uh so
I could just
I mean I could I mean you just imagine
like a Twitter space with like zielinski
and Putin like how else are these two
going to talk right like can't you
imagine if you try to set it up on Zoom
like it never happens never have too
many delegates like just imagine the way
it happened like sitting there like
until he's live is live right just
jumping in it's hilarious
um